um consistency i think is the number one
thing that people forget i have not
missed tweeting a day in three years
if you do you lose your spot in the
relevancy engine with twitter
so twitter every day uh there's there's
like 90
of consumers and 10 of us creators well
the creators create content for the
board consumers the consumer session and
the product
and twitter needs to figure out how to
hook them immediately
and so twitter goes to all their
previous engaged content and they go
well
who do they engage with every day and if
they've built up a habit of engaging
with myself
then they're like well let's give them a
damn hell tweet but if i don't tweet
that day
then there may be like oh let's give
them a chris tweet or someone else's
tweet
because they need to go hook them
immediately and then if that engagement
loop gets built with them over time
then also slowly start to lose relevancy
with them
so consistency is absolutely the most
important thing on twitter and most
of these channels
yeah i feel like i can rule the world i
know i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
no days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back